thank you
um
somebody
and
um
[Music]
throughout the year right so it's going
to be different
um and then uh
just quickly conclude by talking about
how the operationalize okay
um
it's also very important
[Music]
for example
there are other very important areas
everybody knows quite delays because of
weather is like a big thing uh
[Music]
um and there are some lot of workers
you know which uh Industries
so um 80 percent of all our students at
least
in this area okay so
um
thank you so what what is the
implication energy
energy
fixing the
fixing the uh you know
vegetation proximately our lives would
specifically here we are focused on okay
if we have you know whether a cause or
which who gets discoveries
in the next few Horizon use the term
Horizon zero to 24 hours
seven days what the outages how many
outages
in specific areas of the clients
so if you don't have something like this
you have a three-day storm usually
though you know the utility company
starts restoring down to the storm is
first okay but with the predictive uh
solution they can plan and they can
place their two at least 12 hours ahead
before it was allowed to start treatment
and that makes a big difference in terms
of them serving the plants in some
countries
utilities actually take a penalty for
every hour as doubt it is you know are
happening
um and you know they also spend millions
of dollars on physical mobilization they
have to plan ahead sometimes you might
think it's a very big storm but actually
it's not and so they may have planned
like a week ahead and you know contract
without you know through from other
companies when
so that's why this kind of solution
comes
so I'm sorry I'm rushing but hopefully
so overall
space prediction solution there's a data
collection
um
generation uh and the model itself is
unique because we're predicting
variables uh you know outages from my
area okay so at the same time you also
have to credit or not so rare you know
like in the summer in an area like in
the South tropical events are very
common 100 stops it's very common uh and
on a daily basis there will be like
sometimes you know you just have to uh
and when you know a video of scoring
these ones every hour you know
continuously and showing the results
story
but we also use like infrastructure
density because the weather is
otherwise it can
um you know bias the data
but you also use other data sets from
the classroom historically what is
translator so they can evaluate the
model settings
and why we get the data
and we have every day
they also identify these were our
specific stock areas in this specific
Regional terms can move as well so we
want to understand how their storms are
how they have identified this class and
how they have accumulated the data from
each of these stuff
um there's something called a
mobilization plan you know how do they
mobilize their crew so here under within
100 outages in a day they probably will
mobilize uh you know sparringly but if
they have you know 100 to 200 they might
use their own crew if they have over a
thousand poundages
they start contacting software so they
typically have a mobilization plan at
each station Garden that's within the
region you know smaller area operations
center within the region which comprises
multiple operations centers
ourselves like depending on how the
vegetation is close to our life because
most of the chemistries
because of that
has been
you know maintained recently our new
asset has been released
so this is kind of like the background
of the problem why they're doing this so
I'm going to give to a Handover
challenge
so the goal here is to use wireless data
to predict while we're into the office
so we have to give us that always
underwater data
alternatives are relatively easy to
upgrade it because all this is available
after Operation Center level so yeah
this is
from the operation standard should be a
polygon that covers the CDR area that
the utensil company is a
list of so
um all this data is available at the
operations under level and available at
a based on the time and in order to
Market with a validity not we want to
aggregate all this data and weather data
to office to office on the level and
also to a 24 hours even though level uh
we will explain that more in an exercise
um so weather data is a little bit hard
to aggregate because first whatever data
is as a more granular level so you can
see the
question on the counter is the small 0.4
kilometers great point so whether data
is available every hour at this
granularity so the first challenge is
that we have a lot of
that we need to handle
so we use Pi spark to handle the data
volume and the second aspects of the
welding application is the order of
immigration because weather data is
available as a small anywhere now and
also whether it has a little bit at
hourly level so uh you know always
everything to our 24 hours rolling
window plus uh Operation Center level so
for some features like maximum features
whether we take maximum across our
Bridge our maximum across 22 hours it
doesn't matter the other doesn't matter
for some features but for features like
average if you want to calculate the
average wind gusts that comes with
aggregate the average and you may do a
temporal according to argument after
this special first it depends on the
meteorology meaning so like no matter
what we choose it has to make sense from
a physiology perspective
so these are the features we used nearly
in the model uh wooden glass is the most
important feature because a small short
but strong wind gusts that can bring
down vegetations and if the vegetation
will happen to be located close to a
power line or to a power where it's an
organization for angles infrastructure
it will cost all these damages
and the second group of features are the
precipitation feature of this effect
always use the precipitation make the
style moisture value or high so the pole
that varied in the soil will come loose
so uh with the soy moisture very high
and the rest of the wind or at a certain
weather condition combination it will
bring down the power line and slow ice
feature however how it works is uh in
the winter snow and ice could accumulate
on the power line so it will add a lot
of weight so I'm when the wind blows
itself and temperature feature in the
winter below are about three reasons how
many times it's a big difference in the
model and then that's the new
temperature is infrastructure feature so
we use this feature indirectly and
directly in the model so this feature
including number of holes and number
lines of mirrors are a number of length
of lines this is like a different
features describe the infrastructure of
the client so we use this feature
directly in the model and also more
importantly when we aggregate future I
would provide that they're here for
example we calculated hours with gas
with your weight the grid points which
is in this slide so if the grid points
is close to infrastructure we will wait
more for those green points it is not
close to anywhere with no use any
information from those and it is a far
away we'll still use it but could last
week on it so these are the average
future aggregation
so after the future and revision before
we go to the modeling uh the one thing
we need to make sure is to chat with
different colleges we use this extender
a basic sanity check on the data set
itself like a lot of you guys stay out
and all this data itself but some
features are some patterns we have
always run the movie with multiple data
set together for example this is what we
call long tail problem so the the black
line here is the observation or as a
employers all his tickets is the sum of
the all these tickets and the other one
blue and the red they are wind vast and
the cumulative precipitation I mean this
is basically a scenario so in the
beginning of May 5th the outage came
down slowly but the weather event has
already passed like the weather you want
to start from day fourth seventh grade
is a PC at the end of May 4th in the
beginning of May 5th wind gusts and the
precipitation came down but the outage
only came down slowly so this could
simply because during the storm people
do not have access to phones or do not
have access to Internet so they cannot
make the phone call to report the audit
so the the artists come with the power
companies that I don't collectors
tickets to our windows down but a few
hours after the storm after the worst
time or like one or two days after the
worst time people are also like start to
calling so so that's why we have a long
tail like this Dash box in the box like
we have a long tail of all these tickets
so this is very common for almost all
the big Stones because big storms the
the welding event May only happens on
one day but the inspired can can go on
for like three five days or even longer
so but this uh I think a type of data
will be confusing to the model because
uh there is no better investment but we
require the high outage ticket so we
simply remove those data from the model
from the training data
and the second scenario is similar to
the first one but last comment the first
one is very common this one has less
common this is where we have a large
Stone event and draw some alter this is
very high it's almost a hundred outages
and but we don't have the weather's
significant weather to support this
strong event so this could because of
um in the accurate cost code so we only
for her we only for half the weather
related objects so if the audience is
not really related so we use Costco to
filter rather related outage so we rely
on the client to provide us a accurate
cost code and also if this cost code is
relevant to whether or not so like some
cost code is just a car unload or reason
they specified and we have possible like
that so in that case
um the course code on the relative is
may not cause the bad weather but we
um
who are included in the model so this
could cause a this like second scenario
where we have a peak in the artist but
there's nothing happening in the weather
side so we also remove this type of data
from the training data
the third scenario is a little bit
different so these are in the offset
case this is we already have a higher
weather uh weather value but uh low
office data so the office here is only
uh four like four others will consider
it has Argentina is where we do not need
any mobilization so this is a good cause
of rather the cost code or the the
rather data like other alternative
technology but uh no matter what reason
we remove those data from the train is
at
the second data challenge is related to
the characteristic of the targeting of
delicious of his data so always we have
um is the radar event so in this case
the artists did have range from zero to
two thousand so most of the days like in
the very bottom
with our routine day so this account for
unfortunately even like 92 93 of the
data so those these are the days that we
call it Blue Sky day like globalization
as needed uh so we don't need to do
anything and what we want to predict is
uh some of this and the extreme some
days extreme studies happen very rare
like only maybe once or twice a year
like we are historically alvaries
significant in the whole story
um so in order to handle this wide range
and start staying issue
um this is also this is a data challenge
but it's also a modeling challenge so we
build our rebrands or to classify the
data person based on the weather event
you build a model to classify it says
the storm there is a routine day and
first time they have a certain model
routinely have another set of model and
for the they have sparsity so the way we
aggregate tickets to uh 24 hours even
though instead of every hour like we do
projects every hour in this hour away
project before the next coming four
hours so this is not to handle the scar
State issue another way we handle last
day issue with um if the client does not
have enough discount there because each
client has different uh lines of the
data sometimes they only have two years
or three years of data so we only have a
handful of events in the data set so in
that case uh sometimes we group several
operation centers together and to build
one model for the group of operation
centers and if the client has like five
six years data and has enough voltage
event to model the win yeah we don't
need to program
so these are the uh two data challenges
um I'm talking about modeling uh we
tried a bunch of uh Russian learning
algorithms so we have a model structure
like random for instance so here are we
just open the environmental squares that
is a regressor we used in the whole
model structure
um and when we test the data also we
built and data we built the model this
historic data but in operation
operationally like we were trying to do
the same on your UI they uh the the
forecaster is based on forecast
the forecast of audience is based on the
forecast of weather so when we build a
model and test the model we do it on
both data set historical other data and
forecast the weather data and because of
the large range of the wide range of the
office data we don't can calculate
accuracy or just
RSM is just based on the individual
hours or the individual hours prediction
of the individual days prediction
because the number on the routine they
could be very small and a small number
is rather large uh their score so we how
we do it is when it Aggregates the
office data or the actual angles actual
and prediction by exam so it's the
advantage based instead of prediction
this or the day or hour it is so we'll
create something like a stone profile
um so for the storm like we have some a
in location a what's a prediction what
is the actual what is the arrow so we
use one number to some summarize the
song have in our specific location and
after building this stock profile we
calculate the accuracy or the hit score
the arms based on that and another
important perspective of aspect of the
of the accuracy is a foreign
for routine days the routine days almost
there is like another more than 90
percent of days where we have blue sky
no other event
um so for those days we do not want to
predict the office well it will cause
there are no values and the people
it has a company but it does not saying
that it is
as well so exactly Imagine by a false
alarm
so with the head and the first one we
just choose a lot uh if we have a lot of
parameters to show will be utilize we
utilize some automatic tools to
automatically algorithm to help us do
the first round of model selection if we
have like 10 years thousands of models
so we utilize a political work as one of
our techniques we have other things too
and also after the first round we also
based our client preference to a select
the model to like some client need for
high Patriot some weapons who are known
for Salon grade and some may uh like
focus on the median sidestorms and focus
on the Very extreme sound so based on
the current requirements with 2017
around the selection oh yeah this is a
meltdown by one step tuition yeah
foreign
[Music]
um
foreign
mobilization level and he's predicting
your organizations right uh
[Music]
but the actual was 102k which is
immobilization
so sometimes they just want to know
which level they're trying to have and
that's that's what drives their
operation so we have a framework that we
have just based on each time
like
learn they said we want to focus on the
media and stuff I know when we get a
report
anyway
you tell us which ones
more on the viewers
fancy
so during our building a model and our
conversation was fine uh one question
I've been asked a lot of times also we
asked to ourselves is that why are the
model is predicting this number
um especially with the Iran is
approaching the customer the client who
wants to know is this number reliable
and based on what feature I don't
predicting this I'll based on what uh
you know what artificial including so
because of this we built this uh explain
the explanation tools and so we have a
standard side of the explanatory tools
like shop online this is
um so in addition to that we also build
the local explainer like constantive
analysis something that analysis entry
analysis so contrastive analysis is uh
when we have two predictions and they
are close to each other but the
predictions are very different so so
we're trying to walk away from
prediction a to prediction B why is the
change so much or what features driving
this prediction to to which direction so
contrasting analysis to answer that
question sustain the analysis is to is
also giving a specific prediction
um if I change the wind Blaster if I
increase it by one University
College wheelchair and stuff and the
result so it's a scientific overall
feature email prediction and tree
analysis is also giving you one point so
all these are Global experimentar so we
explain a specific uh prediction not
just sound like a visual impotence
Global explorator so uh tree analysis we
use three analysis to uh is uh our
prediction on the prediction we want to
say what uh features and what what the
data in the training data that makes
this uh prediction over predicted
we have an example on the trio analysis
in the next is Slide
okay so first of all this is uh over
prediction
um so in this case we choose the number
of trade uh five hundreds so the
prediction is uh 17.28 this is the over
prediction and something to a point that
is the average of 500 trees so in order
to find what trees that cause the over
prediction we plug the tree gaps uh on
the x-axis and the prediction on the Y
so you can see the top three points that
are far away from all the rest of the
points these are the top three traits
that across the or prediction and there
are also like maybe some points in the
middle of operation but we try to
evaluate we try to eliminate the problem
there's no ballet also we pick the most
uh see we are the values to trade in the
forward step and the second card is the
same data presenting the different way
so you see the
um the circle is three dots and the
second charge is a small bar that's on
the very end of chart is close to 140
and most of the trees have prediction
anywhere around zero to find it so we
want to see what caused this situation
to predict to 140 actually this is a
four Trace it's three point that it's
Fortress we actually have exactly two
trades has exactly the same prediction
so we go to each of the four trees to
understand what features and what
conditions that drives the prediction
the prediction here is like 138 almost
140 so with this condition we go back to
the training data and the filter based
on the condition and pick up those
events that have very high offages and
so this Advanced if the input specific
environments are several successively
events or pair multiple times on illness
that trees that we consider to remove
them so
um this is a part of the data cleaning
but it like uses is we cannot detect
this type of detail uh just based on
descriptive analysis are collecting to
charge together so during the entire
process the normal evaluation model
selection you may say such cases that we
need to remove the data from the model
so after removing this if there is
alignment that caused all the Fortress
to all predict so we remove this and you
have a prediction later after removing
um and this is the second case of um
explainer the shop is a standard tool
that you have to pass up so this is also
an old prediction for the 8.784 by using
sharp we know how much does each filter
contribute to the prediction
um so x-sharp and the three analysis we
cannot describe the same problem from
different perspective this one is the
describing from the future perspective
the other one is the describing from the
GitHub perspective so women look at the
one problem or when you have one
prediction we'll try to explain one
prediction uh we look from different
perspective I'm gonna have a
comprehensive answer and so this the
tool is not only used for support of the
model we also used for
um tuning the model that you will review
the modelers
the children model by cleaning out the
data
um
so basically the point here
is not offer the same
Arrangements
so we need to yeah
[Music]
and then you know we use explainability
too to understand you know what the
issues
it does require us to
visualize you know the performance and
um so this is how the process works but
if you really know
yeah whether
Foods too so what we have done is we
built like a model is getting our
trainings
but basically
just trying to help and we did it a
whole bunch of money
graduation framework that is
being false alarm
and you know and then you know of course
then we have to use the results from the
graduation framework visualize them and
figure out what's up best model based on
the clients
we try to automate as much as possible
oh
so that's that's a true model training I
just want to spend a minute or two of
the coding itself and I mean it's not uh
you know this one might say for our
sporting but I just want to highlight a
few points when it comes to scoring
weather-based ones which many of you may
have done already so we're looking at
some of the scoring machine what a
difference
picking the weather forecasting right
it's now it's the same for predictions
you push it through the same high spot
feature generation only because we have
proper matches uh there are some
differences you know in the where the
vehicles
server
same but then you know we use that one
and then score for that particular off
center and how each offset is different
from maybe others is because their
infrastructure they go
okay so so those are the funds for every
region that we're going to predict you
could use the infrastructure data and
tell us which model to use and then this
is called equipment yeah okay when we
first started doing this seven years ago
um
you know scales performs very well
restore the features and you know the
forecast where the data is not archived
so you know when you start off with a
new plan we don't have our kind of
forecast
it's huge okay so it's not
the historic data is really analysis
so we store this sort of future we when
we go back and retrain ones we can you
know check the performance of their
customers right and we also store the
predictions q and API
so that's the whole pipeline of the
solution
um
yeah and we do the peace and offers us
as these people you know the system is
running for several clients is
predicting every hour and for some
clients the three Horizons
um
we can answer questions
thank you
[Applause]
so I see that you have this hourly
prediction for like 24 hours 48 hours
how this point in your student like next
hour's prediction is like different
that's a different number
yes
so they use them information let's say
this college is coming in you know this
um
[Music]
right so like how does a client
understand
ings
lost the clients see that there will be
out here
enormous outage but in the next hour
they check the prediction again yeah
sometimes it goes down and uh you know
and they at this point either they come
back
okay
let me go back a little bit but most of
the time it doesn't work with that you
know you can see that
and they also will get some information
exactly interesting because they might
see that hey you know the storm is
invest so you you'll see a lot of
outages first here and then you know the
central region and depending on how it's
moving they outages
correct yeah
different parts of distributions that
might have
different AC Network apologies you can
lose the lines and not have a lot of
money it's a good question very good
question yeah it's really hard
okay so the minimum we have gone to is
okay we've got you know historically
they should be able to say they have
this output of this video
and there is not enough
defense of the infrastructible
I will learn that we haven't tried a
very comfortable in Partners to see that
but it is because you know because
even if you have to just you know one
outage in this family have happened like
one year and then yeah
so are you trying to use data from like
training from oxygen theater
individually or across
across all of the theaters so what we do
is being
sometimes we say okay these are the
outages
information
if there is enough
and then use some other characteristics
of the video
and then there are some features that
are specific to them
and
so
that's why you
ran 100 kilometers
um
foreign foreign
yeah I guess my questions
they try to remove those fish with them
are currently that's where one passage
and one will speed pressure
um yeah
yeah and actually over time University
history
thank you
does it matter uh necessarily
eventually like there's a lot of some
trees right as there's three certain
things that takes down like say like a
car accident deposit good like that
might happen more likely because yeah
that it depends on how the price is
the biggest episode as we've been
missing you know sometimes
so I mean I guess you know they're also
putting the course
collecting out Institute right so yes
they may have marketers yeah because
we're in college tomorrow yeah
thank you